[Music]
this is like pretty legit okay that's
like a long list I'm pretty pleased
you're saying that I'm definitely
feeling it I mean this is I mean 300
feet of these ultimately we want to get
down into the gorge let's repeal out the
ridge that's a great idea
[Music]
this is like pretty legit okay
ultimately we want to get down into the
gorge three solo climber Alex Honnold
and I are high up in the Swiss Alps
trying to get to the bottom of this
ravine
that's Rafael out there bridge Segretti
all right can we try and do it from here
you sure do we have this much rope yeah
we're gonna need this we're gonna need
the extra length and also the emergency
length as well
[Music]
for organdy counterbalance repel you go
one side I go the other as long as we go
at the same time it's gonna work or in
the longer your poison Fredrik this is
the technique that the Special Forces
use a lot because it's fast and it
doesn't actually require anything to
anchor to but we're gonna need all of
our rope and the spare rope to reach the
bottom of this one this will be about a
300-foot counterbalance rappel and by
using the same rope Alex and I will
attempt to descend simultaneously but if
one of us puts weight on the rope
without the counterweight to the other
person Alex or I could plummet to the
bottom of this ravine so we've got to
make sure we go at the same time and
maintain the same speed during our
descent the thing is what I do know is
there's gonna be a lot of friction still
on these bits and that is the sort of
stuff that can cut ropes I don't want to
do something that protects any spare
socks I mean I guess you could use my
socks yeah I mean there's some of the
back got a spare one here for night
there's a lot of abrasion on these wires
little bits of metal sticking up that
just sort of thing that will cut through
rope really easily especially if we
start bouncing on this thing as we're
descending so I reckon let if we put on
the top of that that is a very
improvised rope protector
I think it's good it's gonna run through
that this is the most bomber about my
entire life
okay here we go okay so still
suspiciously like driving out of the
plan yeah
why here we go okay so we gotta go at
the same time yeah maybe not too much of
the same time so we don't rag each other
yo Eddie three two one see ya
[Music]
should we like stay a little bit apart
yeah
so bouncy yeah that's why that's where
put the road protection in okay we'll
get a bit little speed now okay
she makes the time I forego super-slow
we guess to the grave
that is a frickin amazing rappel yeah
it's awesome
hey here's a long ways that's a pleasure
that's a lovely your pals super fun to
let on I think the socks add some nice
padding that's just that's how you do it
[Music]
you